Bonjour, ça va toujours en 2019 ?
C'est encore moi Vladimir Cagnolari
qui vous parle d' Abidjan.
Abidjan dans 50 ans.
Abidjan en 2069 !
J 'ai eu de la chance,
comme j'ai été téléchargées dans le futur,
on m'a dispensé de la paperasse
pour entrer dans le pays.
Mais en 2069 croyez moi,
c'est pas simple d'avoir un visa pour l'Afrique.
L'ordre du monde a basculé,
et puis depuis que les états unis
d'Afrique sont devenues une réalité,
le continent pèse lourd et c'est le reste du monde qui désormais essaye de venir s'installer ici.
La roue tourne, et c'est pas mauvais !
Ici, l'Afrofuturisme c'est une idée d'avant
avant...
Un mouvement dont parle encore certains vieux.
Moi, j'ai un peu triché, j'ai l'âge
que j'avais en 2019,
mais comme je vis comme 50 ans plus tard, je me rappelle bien des choses avant.
Alors, quand on me pose la question où je
reparle de cette petite recherche que
j'avais mené en 2019 avec l'aide de Simon Decreuze et Sinatou Saka.
Je vous ai parlé du succès de Black Panther,
des penseurs, aussi, qui avaient préparé le terrain de l'Afrofuturisme.
Aujourd'hui, je vais vous parler de certains artistes afro-américains qui en sont des piliers.
Et si je fouille bien dans ma mémoire, la
toute première fois que j'avais entendu parler d'eux,
c'était chez une amie chanteuse...
Elle s'appelle Mélissa Laveaux !
Née au canada de parents haïtiens,
et c'est elle qui m'avait raconté sa passion pour une auteure afro-amériacine
qui s'est illustrée dans les romans de sciences-fiction.
Son nom, Octavia Butler.
Considérée comme une figure majeure de l'Afrofuturisme !
Alors je suis retourné chez mélissa pour qu'elle m'en dise un peu plus...
Mélissa Laveaux aime les plantes, les tisanes,
les proverbes qui émaillent les conversations téléphoniques de sa mère
les zins – c’est à dire en créole haïtien les potins qu’on se raconte entre copines,
mais aussi les tarots, la nourriture de son enfance, sa guitare, et enfin, bien sûr...
La science fiction.
Mélissa, si je te dis Afrofuturisme, qu'est ce que tu me dis ?
"In the future we exist !"
"Dans le futur on existe", si on traduit en français, ça veut dire quoi pour toi ?
Pour moi c'est...De penser à tous les
films qui parlent du futur,
ou même quand les gens y consacrent à penser à concevoir de l'avenir,
ils le conçoivent avec des personnes racisées en tête...
Quand tu dis "racisées", c'est à dire ?
C'est à dire des personnes non-blanches (*Rires)
Les gens, à qui on pense,
quand on pense "étrangers".
Pour moi, c'est un terme qui m'a...
Genre, juste la culture de l'Afrofuturisme
m'a beaucoup aidé personnellement parce que moi je suis déjà une grande fan de science-fiction
Pendant très longtemps je pensais que la science fiction c'est un truc de garçons blancs
parce qu'il n'y avait que des garçons qui la lisaient.
Et qui l'écrivait même souvent !
Et qui l'écrivait.
Mais ce qui est vachement bien, c'est que moi je me suis branché assez tôt, quand j'étais jeune,
à la série Star Trek !
Et Gene Roddenberry qui a créé cette série,
est un réalisateur et un scénariste juif américain
qui voulait avoir un casting divers, inclusif.
Et en fait, c'est la première
série où il y à une femme noire
qui n'est pas une bonne ou qui n'est pas une prsotitué à la télévision.
Et l'actrice, elle a la même quitté cette série.
Et du coup, il y a Martin Luther King Jr. qui est un grand fan de Star Trek
lui a supplié de ne pas
quitter la série. Et c'est là qu'elle y est retournée.
il a fallu que ce soit Martin Luther King
qui vienne lui réclamer de rester ?
Et tu vois que  Martin Luther King
lui aussi était Afrofuturiste avant même que le terme il existe.
Parce que si tu penses aux discours, son discours fameux "i have a dream" - "j'ai un rêve",
tu penses à l'avenir, tu conçois de
l'avenir avec toi en tête !
Pas que toi en tête, mais qui soit un avenir inclusif.
Surtout, c'est assez marrant parce que quand tu lis, et moi je lis énormément,
ou je regarde énormément de littérature, de médias
dystopiques...
Un futur qui est le contraire d'une utopie (*Rires)
C'est pas la fin du monde mais c'est genre...
"worst case scenario", le pire cas du futur...
Genre quelque chose qui a été poussé à
l'excès, et ce qui est assez marrant par exemple
c'est juste les aliens, qui sont
des grands mollusques verts, versus les blancs
Les blancs étant censé représenter des humains ?
Etants censés représenter
la planète terre ! Ce qui est
assez bizarre, donc ça c'est cool quand j'étais
plus jeune, j'ai vu "Independance Day" où Will Smith sauve la terre...
Ah d'accord ! C'est nouveau (*Rires)
C'était pas commun avant d'avoir un héros noir
qui sauve la planète !
Du coup, pour retourner à Star Trek.
Star trek, il y avait Soul, qui est un des
ingénieurs, il y a un écossais,
il y a Houra, et du coup c'est un casting
divers et c'est après afin qu'on voit ça.
Gene Roddenberry a fait plusieurs
séries star trek à travers les années.
quelques choses comme 40 ans, là il est mort.
Gene Roddenberry va faire énormément de série
et chaque fois quand tu vois une série Star
Trek il ya toujours un casting inclusif.
Il ya toujours des personnes et par
exemple dans un actionnariat jolly qui
aveugle
il y a des vraiment c'est hyper
intéressant et pas que au niveau des dix
espèces de gens n'y a pas que des
humains et c'est vraiment au niveau de
différentes cultures différentes
habilité une différentes orientations
sexuelles par exemple ça ç'a toujours
été hyper intéressant dans les séries de
star trek de jj
pour moi c'est un peu le début de mon
obsession avec la science fiction états
unis première fois que je me suis dit un
accord moi aussi
dans un futur où il ya rappelé and
technology et star à moi je peux exister
c'est pas que un truc où c'est les
blancs qui se bat contre les aliens ou
c'est bizarre je trouve ça vraiment
bizarre en fait quand il ya autant de
séries que j'ai grandi où je me voyais
pas du tout à la fois que je suis venu
ici ici bien d'ailleurs pour ça que
c'est du devoir c'est parce que c'est
toi qui la première m'a parlé d'octavia
butler inquiète donc une hauteur as pour
américaine j'aimerais que moody's
un peu plus qu' elle étai pourquoi elle
a compté pour toi passé le triste c'est
triste des années 70 80 qui a écrit
énormément de livres de science-fiction
hyper important qui a rapporté
énormément de prix mais qui ne trouve
que elles prêtent encore plus reconnu
aujourd'hui l'influencé énormément
d'auteur donc c'est sûr que là je
regarde les livres je regarde kindred
qui est le premier livre que j'ai 10 ans
arrivait pas drôle qui justement elle
imagine qu'une femme est trop vu de
manière de retourner dans le passé donc
des fois la science-fiction ses
pansements le futur mais des fois c'est
le passé on réinvente en revisitant le
revisitant elle prend une jeune femme
qui retourne dans le passé à l'époque de
l'esclavagé pour pouvoir changer les
choses en fait est qu'ils se rencontrent
horrifiée qu'en fait si elle change tout
si elle permet à ses ancêtres de
s'évader en fait tu attrapes année parce
que ses ancêtres la destinée de saison 7
est inévitablement liée à celle des
maîtres
parce que c'est la même famille
les viols étaient assez commun et du
coup la plupart des afro-américains sont
métis dans un autre bouquin qui a fait
de nous de série la terre est prend fin
en fait être des aliens qui arrivent
pour récupérer certains humains les
arrange
et ils disent ah mais vous avez un
cancer vous allez mourir mais on vous a
arrangé et on vous a fusionné en fait
avec notre staff et vous pourrez créer
une nouvelle espèce et on va vous
reposer dans une autre planète et vous
allez vous créer comme ça à recréer
comme ça j'en sais juste fait des aliens
que l'on qu'ils fassent de planète en
planète wild une planète est déficiente
récupère quelques spécimens les mélange
à d'autres spécimens comme si tu allais
vaches et tout créer notre espace et
puis les déposer ailleurs
du coup ça repart de 10 par la
colonisation de forcer une intégration
culturelle aux gens parce que du coup
cette personne qui a été
ils ont changé son code adn carrément
ils ont fait des traitements il la met
dans une famille de leur espace pour que
celui ci un peu à eux et après ça doit
aider quelques étudiants c'est vraiment
genre moi je revoyais des histoires un
esclavage ou genre les esclaves qui
viennent par exemple du nigeria doivent
apprendre à recréer des plats français
mais avec des ingrédients venant des
tropiques je crée pour moi ça me parlait
vachement il y avait un autre qui par
moments de magie ça ça m'a beaucoup
rappelé des antilles parce que il
l'amérique du sud en général et dans la
littérature des amériques pour les afro
américaine mais aussi d'amérique
centrale et là-dessus américaine il y à
ce truc de réalisme match c'est qu'on la
magie s'invite dont le réel en fait la
magie s'invite dans les récits de mais
de manière très subtile comme si c'était
le complément normal y'a pas genre oh
mon dieu il ya un esprit qui arrive
alors évidemment après avoir causé avec
mélissa laveaux je me suis procuré un
des livres d'octavia butler qui a
commencé à publier dans les années 70
1979 vous m'entendez délivre l on a
écrit beaucoup mais tous n'ont pas été
traduits en français
alors j'ai opté pour le seul qui était
disponible chez mon libraire un roman
intitulé novices
celui qui n'est pas en capacité de se
projeter dans le futur ici pour voir la
pince la novice
c'est cette gamine qui a l'air d'avoir
10 ans et qui se réveille un jour
atrocement blessés dans l'obscurité
d'une grotte seule angoisse et met son
corps elle s'en rend compte peu à peu à
la faculté de se réparer tout seul de se
régénérer tout ça bien sûr là des
boussoles car elle n'a plus aucune idée
de qui est laid ni même de comment elle
s'appelle elle va devoir le découvrir et
comprendre pourquoi comme les vampires
elle se nourrit de sang retrouvant ses
semblables
elle va devoir réapprendre à être une
hymne à cette société dont les membres
vivent depuis des siècles avec leur
symbiote des humains qui ne demande qu'à
être mordu oui parce que la morsure des
zina et douce jouissive même presque
érotique pour les humains qui
s'attachent à leur hymne à et peuvent
ainsi vivre jusqu'à 200 ans
la novice c'est donc cette jeune fille
de 53 ans ce qui est jeune pour unis n'a
qu' en renouer avec ses pairs doit
deviner pourquoi sa propre famille a été
assassinée
shory puisque c'est son nom est noir ses
parents ont mélangé ses gènes dina avec
ce duel maine loire
et c'est ainsi grâce à sa mélanine
qu'elle peut vivre nos jours quand tous
les autres
zina d'or mais deviennent alors
vulnérable chez lézina dont les doyens
ont traversé des siècles un oui certains
plus de 600 ans et bien parmi eux
certains veulent sa perte digère mal
cette atteinte à la pureté de leur race
pour eux shory la métisse est une menace
novice et le dernier roman publié du
vivant d'octavia butler une romancière
fascinante maintes fois primé qui en
1998 pour la petite histoire imaginait
un candidat à la présidentielle qui se
faisait élire grâce au contrôle de la
réalité virtuelle
son slogan mais qu' american break again
ça ne s'invente pas bien ça s'invente en
fait en tout cas c'est bien vingt ans
auparavant de l'anticipation de claire
était inquiète de la course aux
tripatouillages génétique à laquelle se
livrent les scientifiques
et puis surtout elle faisait place dans
les futurs qu'elle imaginait à toute
l'humanité
c'est à dire aux femmes et aux hommes
dans leur diversité
abidjan 2069 dimanche dernier j'étais du
côté du plateau
aujourd'hui un quartier de loisirs et de
détente mais aussi deux fois
bien sûr il ya toujours la grande
mosquée et puis la cathédrale saint-jean
qui depuis dix ans est devenu nomade
oui elle avait déjà la lure d'un
vaisseau spatial dans les années 80
quand elle a été construite mais depuis
2000 55
elle est devenue un vrai vaisseau chaque
dimanche elle peut ainsi se déplacer
dans plusieurs villes du pays et revenir
à son parking habituel au sommet du
plateau et puis vous savez peut-être à
abidjan il ya le fameux immeuble
pyramide ça je vous en reparlerai mais à
votre époque en 2019
il était abandonné et puis semblait
promis à une destruction prochaine
quelques années plus tard il a été
racheté et rénové et c'est là que se
sont installés les disciples de sonnerat
un jazzman visionnaires du siècle
dernier et pionnier de ce qu'on a appelé
la préfecture isme du dimanche donc cédé
6 plus organise des cérémonies où le
jazz la danse et les forces cosmiques
résonne et on y entend toujours en
ouverture le morceau culte de sonnerat
space is deplace l'espace c'est
l'endroit
m
ce pas
mais
lorsque débuta le premier concert donné
par l'ipea galactique wissocq arkestra à
saint paul de vence le public resté
stupéfait devant un spectacle qui excédé
en tout point ce que l'on pouvait
imaginer un concert de l'orchestré
c'est à la fois une sorte de rites
magiques une grande fête et cheveux les
un tourbillon de lumières et de sons un
défoulement ludique qui obéit à deux
grandes lignes de force sous-jacente et
ne sombre jamais dans l'incohérence où
la vulgarité des films sont projetés
derrière les musiciens vue de new york
ou de chicago scènes de rue répétition
de l'orchestré fusée partant pour la
lune dieux égyptiens ou guerriers
africains en plus mais les lumières se
tamisent ou illumine la scène tandis que
sonnera lancent des éclairs que les
danseuses brandissent des emblèmes des
objets symboliques
puis tout à coup un musicien saute à
pieds joints au dessus de la boule de
verre lumineuse censé représenter
quelques instants auparavant la toute
puissance du soleil
j'ai retrouvé ses impressions dans le
dictionnaire amoureux du jazz de patrice
blanc francard un bréviaire
indispensable vous avez compris sonara
n'était pas un petit personnage né en
1914 aux etats-unis dans l'alabama où la
ségrégation était la plus rude et
sauvage
le jeune herman blanche oui c'est son
nom à l'état civil devient très tôt
musiciens délaissent les études et
préfèrent s'enfermer chez ses parents où
défilent d'autres amis musiciens
c'est qu'en 1936 il à l'époque 22 ans il
vit une expérience mystique une
expérience du troisième type
il affirme avoir été amenée sur saturne
et y avoir rencontré les autochtones qui
habite ceux ci l'aurait sommé d'arrêter
ses études pour se consacrer à la
musique
oui car la sienne est entendu dans tout
le cosmos et a le pouvoir d'empêcher le
monde de sombrer dans le chaos
franchement pour expliquer à ses parents
qu'on arrête les études on pouvait pas
trouver et plus créatifs comme excuse en
tout cas lui qu'on surnomme sony se fera
appeler sonnera en référence à ré le
dieu soleil de l'egypte ancienne seconde
guerre mondiale éclate il a à l'époque
25 ans et refuse de se faire enrôler
du coup la sanction tombe ils passent
par la case prison et il en ressort
abîmées alors il quitte le sud et
s'installe à chicago c'est là qu'il
démarre laventure de mark
pour ne pas se faire enfermer dans les
cases manichéenne d'une amérique en noir
et blanc sonnera décide de se forger sa
propre histoire sa propre identité
les planètes de notre système solaire
demeure un viol et inexplorée donc on
peut tout y reconstruire comme marcus
garvey prêchant pour le retour en
afrique des noirs du nouveau monde
sonnerat lui dit avoir pour mission de
préparer les noirs à l'ère spatiale
on invite même à donner en tant
qu'artiste invité ainsi que deux
conférences à l'université de berkeley
en californie le sujet du cours
l'homme noir et le cosmos nous sommes en
1971 et la liste de livres qu'il donne à
ses étudiants montre bien qu'il a
absorbé lui même tout un tas d ouvrage
qui parle de l'egypte noir dans la
droite ligne des travaux de cheikh anta
diop dont je vous parlais tantôt quand
on parle de medupi on parle de lorient
l'egypte ne sait pas on lui propose
alors de développer ses idées mais cette
fois ci dans un film de fiction ce sera
space is the place
sorti en 1974 voilà un film assez fou ou
sonnera qui s'est installée sur votre
planète avec l'art kerstrat revient sur
terre
vêtu comme un pharaon pour organiser le
voyage des noirs d'amérique vers ce
nouvel éden comment compte-t-il s'y
prendre et bien en les télés portant
grâce à la puissance de sa musique
évidemment les barons qui tiennent les
ghettos noirs ne laisserons pas faire
pas plus que ceux qui servent les
intérêts de la classe dominante
américaine la nasa même essaye de le
kidnapper pour qu'il révèle ses secrets
bref vous l'avez compris voilà un film
fou mais qui contient tous les possibles
et surtout l'immense liberté de se
définir de s'inventer dont sonnera
faisait preuve dans ses discours comme
dans sa musique lui qui imaginaient sur
ses claviers toutes sortes de sons les
plus inouïes ou bien qui demandait à ses
musiciens de prendre un instrument qu'il
ne connaissait pas pour jouer ensemble
c'est vrai ça comment pourrions nous
inventer quelque chose de nouveau si
nous avons peur de l'inconnu et cette
démarche ne pouvait que plaire à maïwenn
a hier voici je vous l'avais déjà
présente et qui en 2019 coordonnait la
plateforme black stuff youtube sina tout
ça qu'a l'avait rencontrée et seaway
l'aï roissy ne voulait surtout pas
définir l'afro futurisme pour ne pas le
figer et bien elle y voyez tout de même
trois principes fondamentaux
voici le premier fiction fiction et en
pwm à un outil qui permet de travailler
notre rapport au réel
au-delà de cette habitude qu'ont à
reconstituer des couples des couples
d'opposition comme ça des dichotomies
qui sont magie technologies ou virtuels
surnaturel ou histoire avec un grand h
récit et l'âge revient aussi à cette
idée de sonnerat sonnera c'est pas un
personnage de conan c'est un personnage
qui parle des principes et c'est ce
qu'il dit dans space 2 places à un
moment donné tu parles voilà des jeunes
qui doivent avoir peut-être entre 16 et
20 ans 1,80 existe je n'existais pas
vous êtes des mythes
vous comme moi vous n'existez pas dans
cette société vous n'avez pas de droit
et en fait c'est là que vient tout
l'idée aussi de la métaphore et la
mythologie impro futuriste la juste une
mythologie
il s'agit de fuir dans un idéal est à
nouveau ce rapport à l'utopie c'est
quelque chose de très concret et de dire
que à partir du moment où on identifie
ce qu'elle réel donc le réel en tant que
citoyen c'est-à-dire pouvoir voter
pouvoir donner son avis à voir
une capacité de consommation at-elle
quotas blabla c'est pas nous qui avons
décidé des critères mais si les critères
sont ceux ci et qu'en fait tu n'as pas
accès à ces critères ça veut donc dire
que tu n'as pas accès à cette réalité
c'est à peu près aussi sans que ça et
c'est ça le jeu aussi de l'affreux
futurisme et de son rapport à la fiction
constante la fiction employés pour
ausculter la réalité l'a retourné et
essayer de la changer
c'est d'ailleurs aussi ce qu'ils
aimaient faire georges clinton un des
rois de la musique fun
george clinton était fan de star-trek
lui aussi est certainement inspiré par
les délires de seule voix seul bras
devant la maison blanche se demandait où
était la maison noire et d'orge clinton
lui prophétisait déjà dans une chanson
de 1975 1 coupe afro américain à la
maison blanche avec ça pue au funk sap
iphone comme il l'appelait il comptait
bien funky fier les planètes et
d'ailleurs ces concerts avec son groupe
parliament ou d'autres groupes qui
l'avaient funkadelic
quand ils les jouets dans les salles il
vient ça commence et souvent par la
descente d'un ovni avec force effets
pyrotechniques contre le noir et
blanc.c'était le futur en femme qui
colle à une bise aux banques hausse de
special in the air tonight kipopo
apprend que tyson gay a accès
voilà après cette petite pause punk ça
fait toujours du bien
on retrouve dans ma roue et nahio aussi
qui évoque ce qui à ses yeux est le
second pilier de l'affreux futurisme
prospectives ce qui m'intéresse avec la
prospective à nouveau c'est que la
prospective c'est pas juste
je ne sais pas avoir une vision un peu
inspiré de demain nous serons sur une
planète violette avec des fleurs qui
feront 7 mètres de haut et des vaches
sur des roues non la prospective c'est
une analyse possible où deux scénarios
possibles du futur à partir d'éléments
du présent donc la prospective c'est
quelque chose qu'on trouve beaucoup dans
la gestion de risques mais aussi dans
les rapports environnementaux et c'est
un calcul assez simple on a consommé
temps de quotas d'eau en 100 ans
il est fort probable que dans cent ans
il n'y a plus d'eau peut-être qu'il faut
qu'on change notre rapport de
consommation à l'eau donc la prospective
c'est vraiment cette analyse là et toi
mélissa tu en dis quoi
pour moi c'est hyper intéressant de voir
comment il ya une amende auteur de
fiction spéculative d'erfoud tourisme de
science fiction qui arrivent à se mettre
en tête que ce qui arriverait si on
poussait sa à l'extrême ce petit truc
l'art en société c'était poussé à l
extrême qu'est ce qui arriverait et
chaud que ça sert assez important parce
qu'on ne réfléchit pas mais en fait
c'est comme par exemple avec le low cost
les gens essayaient je suis pas
concernée je pas concerné par là et ces
gens des petits par des petits pas vers
la désensibilisation des gens et des
petits pas qui font en sorte qu' ils se
rendent pas compte mais un truc horrible
ils font partie on fait tous partie d'un
truc horrible
là on fait partie de le truc horrible
qui est en train de détruire la planète
dans 50 ans on arrive pour l'accueil et
du coup il ya énormément de ce père
romans et de livres qui parlent de et
deux sont des fictions dystopique ou par
exemple je pense à celui avec le train
transilien qui fait et puis en première
classe il ya les gens aisés 20 la
dernière classe à tous les pauvres et du
cou
c'est marrant comme même dans dans quand
tu reposes l'humanité sur un train il ya
une hiérarchie qui se construit et les
gens qui sont en haut de l'échelle
ils défendent de manière très violente
leur position privilégiée mais très
violente dans ce train nous tenant lieu
de demeure une seule chose se dresse
entre la chaleur de nos coeurs et les
morsures du froid des vêtements des
boucliers aucunement l'ordre l'ordre est
la barrière qui nous préserve du gel
fatale le devoir de chacun dans ce train
de la vie est de remplir le rôle qui lui
est échu
nous sommes tous tenus d'occuper la
place qui nous était prédestiné après ça
il ya un super livre de nelly power qui
s'appelle c'est fini ex a beaucoup de
beaux que félix et beaucoup fait une
expérience d'une femme qui est immortel
enfin tel qu'il est conçu dans un
laboratoire et tout on doit qu'elle est
une femme de 40 ans et du coup elle se
rend compte qu'elle en fait elle chauffe
travail rapidement et tout est en fait
elle se rend compte qu'elle est une
bombe humaine donc elle peut exploser
quand elle est vraiment grand tâche et a
pu exploser
pierre rosnay et c'est marrant parce que
c'est un truc qui entre nous et nos axes
qui était une vraie femme noire que la
science et la science pour donc elle
profite encore de ces cellules parce
qu'ils ont utilisé ces cellules
immortels du coup parce qu'elle avait un
cancer c'est lui qui se démultipliait
manière il
ils ont vendu ces cellules pour qu'il
faut faire des tests pour presque toutes
les maladies dans le monde parce que
c'est les cellules idéal ne meurent
jamais dans ce faire des tests comme tu
veux tellement que les laboratoires ont
été affectées par ces cellules ces
cellules ont même été dans l'espace avec
les cellules de réelles mais brax
pourrait faire le tour de la planète
plusieurs fois par exemple
c'est incroyable c'est ça une vraie
histoire et ça se retrouve dans le livre
de beaucoup fils ex ou c'est une femme
qui est mortelle en même temps il ya
aussi cette histoire très microscopiques
mais aussi général d'une femme qui
arrive vers la ménopause et dites vous
qu'il ya des cas des bouffées de chaleur
et tout mais de transformer ça en jambes
en fait c'est un phénix elle arrive une
différentes phases une sphère en d'étape
de sa vie elle explose nouvel état
phares arrivent et
il ya quelque chose de super intéressant
où c'est un personnage qui est vraiment
à la merci des gens qui l'ont créée qui
ont enfoncé laboratoires qui ont
contrôlé son environnement qui se bat
contre ces gens et qui avec scullion
infliger comme comme sort elle arrive à
en faire quelque chose d'extraordinaire
c'est une vie plutôt triste en fait déjà
pas mal de trucs qui skie son incroyable
qui sont horribles qui lui arrive quand
même eu un destin incroyable et qui
pourrait être une métaphore aussi de ce
que tu disais justement des peuples
qu'ils ont subis et qui transforme sa
part résilience mais en force pour
pouvoir aller de l'avant vers l'avenir
quoi il ya cette métaphore là aussi
c'est ce que je racontais match enfin je
pensais que ça plus clair que ça
d'accord merci de clarifier la ddt
je résume la preuve si j'ai réussi à le
comprendre c'est que c'est que c'était
clair oui c'était clair en tout cas les
fictions comme celle que vient d'évoquer
me dit c'est là vous permettent de
déplacer des situations d'aujourd'hui
dans d'autres époques dans d'autres
mondes
pour mieux comprendre les problèmes qui
nous tenaille dans le présent en ce sens
et c'est ce que rappelle maïwenn highway
si ces fictions ou c'est science fiction
sont toujours politique là profiter à
dents tout pour moi et politiques et
pour politique j'aime beaucoup revenir à
cette idée un peu classique de la
politique ça n'est rien d'autre que le
vivre ensemble
la politique ce n'est pas un programme
politique et étatique
c'est d'abord comment est-ce qu'on veut
vivre ensemble et comment est ce qu'on
peut vivre ensemble
quand est ce qu'on va négocier ensemble
parce qu'en fait on va être sur le même
territoire un espace aussi basiques que
ça ce qui se passe dans une classe
d'école ces politiques ce qui se passe
dans une rame de métro
ces politiques tout est politique et de
ce point de vue là la fraude stylisme
assume et réengage ça souvent
dans ce qu'on a appelé les afro
futurisme peut-être il faut parler au
pluriel on laisse aussi passé c'est
souvent lié au féminisme c'est comme si
c'était devenu un terrain d'expression
privilégié aussi pour les idées de dit
féministe
qu'est ce que tu entends dire hey toi
bien tu vas parler essentiellement
d'auteurs féminins buteur féminine
si tu as un viol et massif est triste
pour moi c'est je pense que si je
choisis ma littérature par rapport à
quelque chose qui me parle je pense que
lire une littérature qui ne prend pas en
compte les combats de différentes
personnes et pas que le combat féministe
mais combien fini soissons il est dans
moi quand je me considère la conf
ministre
c'est un combat qui est inclusive pour
tout le monde donc pour moi c'est
important de miliana littérature qui
prend en compte différents combats parce
que je ne conçois pas de méditer pour un
avenir plus beau en écartant certaines
personnes qui sont soit disant
indésirables et du coup du coup je
prends pour moi c'est important de dire
une température qui peint ce qui est
intéressant justement c'est que ces
littératures parle de personnes
marginalisées en général donc je n'ai
pas un personnage secondaire on n'est
pas un personnage en plus en enflant
arrière nous marginaliser ou les parts
de manière générale dans nos sociétés
ont des personnages principaux
et ça c'est pas toujours le cas dans la
littérature mais ce n'est pas toujours
le cas dans la littérature qui est
notamment publié d'où énormément de gens
qui font défoncer inudo d auto édition
des personnes marginalisées dans les
pays occidentaux
ça peut être des femmes ça peut être les
noirs ça peut être les quais tout ce
qu'on appelle les minorités encore
contre les minorités donc zappé les
personnes trans appelle les personnes
qui ont un handicap sur les personnes
qui sont nommés par un étrangères jean
sellier ya tellement de aujourd'hui
c'est peut être le migrant ça peut être
le migrant aujourd'hui ça c'est une
analyse c'est toujours en fait aussi ses
productions vers le futur une critique
de la société actuelle telle qu'elle
fonctionne en creux puisque outre on
s'intéresse à ceux qui sont rejetés ou
ceux auxquels on ne s'intéresse jamais
dans les choses disons grand public ou
de la culture dominante
ceux qui n'ont pas de voir en fait nan
là dans la culture dominante
ça sert de plateforme aux personnes qui
n'ont pas nécessairement à une voie et
non pas nécessairement un auditoire
cette dimension marginal libertaire qui
défait les catégories pour que chacun
puisse les recomposer comme il veut
c'est à dire on peut être noir et blanc
ont peut être été roué des conservateurs
et révolutionnaire si si ça existe
bref en tout cas on peut ne pas rentrer
dans les cases être hybride métis voilà
une des raisons pour lesquelles la frau
futurisme résiste tant aux définitions
général mais rappelez-vous les rastas
dont je vous ai parlé eux aussi il
n'aimait pas les ismes et les schismes
en tout cas c'est une dimension qu'on a
retenu pas mal de jeunes artistes qui en
un demi-siècle après sonnera lé début
d'octavia butler s'inspire de la
perspective afro futuriste je vous
parlerai de hama prochaine transmission
mais là il faut que je me taise c'est
bientôt l'heure du web c'est le moment
de la soirée à partir duquel tout le
monde doit se taire pour ne pas déranger
son voisin le silence doit s'imposer de
manière absolue ça fait peur on se
trouvait l'an des montagnes le suisse on
est impuissant à puce en infligeant
alors je rigole on est à abidjan
ici on ne s'amuse pas avec le s'amusant
je dois aller prendre mon bain
d'ambiance pas dans un mail à stopper